le 12 février 2015 les dirigeants russes
ukrainiens français allemand signé les
accords de minsk 2 le texte prévoyait
alors plusieurs mesures de sécurité dont
un cessez-le-feu immédiat le retrait des
armes lourdes du front ou encore des
échanges de prisonniers
mais le document contenait aussi tout un
pan politique avec une réforme
constitutionnelle de l'ukraine qui
prévoyait l'octroi d'un statut spécial
aux régions de donetsk et de lougansk
est l'organisation d'élections locales
mais il faut se rendre à l'évidence que
sur le terrain les accords de minsk sont
difficiles à appliquer c'est pour nous
l'opportunité de revisiter cette
situation pouvoir échanger il pouvoir
aussi préparer des rendez vous à venir
et en lien étroit avec le président
hélène ski et la chancelière merkel
nous aurons à considérer l'opportunité
ce qui est bien trouvé d'un nouveau
sommet en format normandie dans les
prochaines semaines si nous arrivons à
configurer les voies d'avancement et sur
le plan politique le cren peine à mettre
en oeuvre les mesures promises
confronté à une farouche opposition
nationaliste le pouvoir ukrainien n'a
pas appliqué les amendements
constitutionnels de décentralisation
exigé aux termes des accords de minsk et
qui avait pourtant été voté par le
parlement malgré la tenue d'un sommet
similaire en octobre 2016 à berlin
réunissant les quatre mêmes chefs d'état
la situation s'enlise dans le donbass
s'ensuivent des années de conflits gelés
de déclarations veine de sanctions
toujours plus nombreux à adopter contre
moscou et d'un cessez-le-feu bafouée
quasi quotidiennement
enfin au printemps 2010 9 le vent du
changement semble souffler sur le cren
métro prochain qu est balayée au second
tour des élections présidentielles par
un nouveau venu en politique issu du
monde du spectacle
volodymyr alinsky élu sur la promesse de
combattre la corruption et de mettre fin
à la guerre dans l'est du pays il paraît
plus ouvert au dialogue que son
prédécesseur
la perspective d'une nouvelle rencontre
format normandie a alors pris corps avec
la visite de vladimir poutine au fort de
brégançon au mois d'août dernier
c'est aussi pour nous l'opportunité de
revisiter cette cette situation de
pouvoir échanger et de pouvoir aussi
préparer des rendez vous à venir et en
lien étroit avec le président de nice
qui est la chancelière merkel nous
aurons à considérer l'opportunité ce qui
est mon souhait
d'un nouveau sommet en format normandie
dans les prochaines semaines si nous
arrivons à configurer les voies
d'avancement visite suivie quelques
semaines plus tard par un échange de
prisonniers historique entre l'ukraine
et la russie
en effet le 7 septembre 2019 deux avions
transportant 35 prisonniers de chaque
côté ont simultanément fait le trajet
entre kiev et moscou
un signal fort et sur le terrain depuis
novembre
les belligérants se sont retirés de
plusieurs secteurs du front
c'est donc le 9 décembre à paris que
s'est tenu un nouveau sommet au format
normandie plein de promesses hélas peu
d'avancées concrètes ils ont été
observés
si ce n'est un nouvel échange de
prisonniers cette fois entre kiev et les
autorités de l'est de l'ukraine qui a eu
lieu le 29 décembre
cinq années ont passé depuis la
signature des accords de minsk et malgré
les efforts en cours
une nouvelle rencontre au format
normandie est prévue dans les mois à
venir pour le moment c'est toujours le
statu quo qui prévaut sur le terrain
[Musique]